SETH VARGO: In this episode
of The Secret Manager video
series, we'll talk about the
principle of least privilege
and how you can limit who
can access your secrets.
Do you want to limit
access to your secrets?
Stay tuned to find out how.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The principle of least privilege
says that an entity must only
be able to access the
information or resources
necessary to perform
its function.
In the context of
Secret Manager,
this means humans and machines
should only have access
to the secrets that are required
to perform their function.
For example, a security
engineer may have full control
to create and manage secrets,
but an application developer
may only have permission
to access a single secret.
But how do we accomplish this?
To tell us more about how to
adopt the principle of least
privilege with Secret
Manager, I think
we need to bring in an expert.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, Nick.
Thanks for joining us today.
NICK MUNARRIZ: Thanks, Seth.
Thank you so much for having me.
SETH VARGO: So Nick is a
software engineer at Google
who works on Secret Manager.
Nick, earlier I was
telling our viewers
about the principle
of least privilege.
Could you tell us
a little bit more
about how Secret Manager helps
users adopt this principle?
NICK MUNARRIZ: Sure, Seth.
So on Google Cloud,
most controls
are implemented using Cloud
Identity and Access Management,
or IAM.
IAM provides very
granular permissions
that are combined into roles.
Secret Manager currently offers
five granular Cloud IAM roles.
First is the Secret
Manager Admin IAM role,
which grants full access to
administer Secret Manager
resources, including creating
and deleting secrets.
Then the Secret
Manager Viewer IAM role
grants permission to
view the secret metadata
on Secret Manager resources, but
it does not include the ability
to access secret payloads.
This is useful for
auditing secrets
without actually seeing
the payloads inside.
Then the Secret Manager
Secret Accessor IAM role
grants the ability to
access secret payloads,
but does not grant any
administrative permissions.
This is useful for humans
and applications that
need to access a secret,
but don't need permissions
to manage those secrets.
The Secret Manager
Version Manager IAM role
grants permission to manage
versions of existing secrets,
but it does not
include the ability
to access secret payloads
or view or update
the metadata on any
secrets themselves.
Finally, the Secret Manager
Version Adder IAM role grants
permissions to add new
versions to existing secrets,
but it does not
include the ability
to access secret payloads or
manage any versions or secrets.
This is useful for
applications that might need
to perform simple rotations.
SETH VARGO: OK, so it sounds
like Secret Manager has
this really nice separation
of concerns between managing
secrets, auditing
secrets, rotating secrets,
and accessing secrets.
So this will definitely
help me adopt that principle
of least privilege.
But wouldn't granting someone
Secret Manager Secret Accessor
permissions give
them access to all
of the secrets in my project?
NICK MUNARRIZ: So
that really depends on
where you grant
that IAM permission.
Secret Manager's IAM roles
can be applied globally
on a whole project or
individually on just
a single secret.
If you grant an
entity, like a user,
the Secret Manager
Secret Accessor role
on the project, then
that entity can access
all the secrets in the project.
But if you grant the Secret
Manager Secret Accessor
to just an entity
on a single secret,
then the entity will only be
able to access that one secret.
SETH VARGO: OK, so it
sounds like if I really
want to follow that
principle of least privilege,
I should apply IAM roles
at the most granular level.
NICK MUNARRIZ: That's right.
Since Cloud IAM's default
policy is to deny,
applying the roles at
the most granular level
is what really helps you
achieve that principle of least
privilege.
SETH VARGO: OK, awesome.
But Google Cloud has
these built-in roles,
like Project Editor
and Project Owner.
How do those built-in roles
map to these Secret Manager
permissions?
NICK MUNARRIZ: That's
a really good question.
So project owners are
kind of super users,
so they have full permissions
to access and manage secrets.
Even if we remove
this permission,
they could just grant
it to themselves,
because they're also full
IAM policy administrators.
SETH VARGO: OK,
that makes sense.
We could take it away,
but they could just
add it back themselves.
NICK MUNARRIZ: Yeah.
However, perhaps unlike
other GCP services,
the ability to access
secrets and the ability
to change IAM
permissions on secrets
is not actually granted to
the Project Editor role,
and that includes the default
Compute Engine Service account.
This means the only
Project Owners and entities
who are explicitly granted
permissions can access secrets
in your project.
SETH VARGO: Awesome.
Thank you so much, Nick.
This really makes it
clearer how Secret Manager
can help to adopt the
principle of least privilege.
OK.
Let's take a look
at how to practice
the principle of least privilege
with Google Secret Manager.
I created a secret that
contains my Twilio API key,
and I need to grant my
Cloud Function permissions
to access that secret.
Now, I could go to
the Cloud IAM settings
and grant my Cloud
Function Service account
the Secret Manager
Accessor permissions.
But as we learned from Nick,
that isn't a best practice,
because that would allow my
Cloud Function to access all
of the secrets in the project.
Instead, we want to follow the
principle of least privilege
and grant access
only to the secrets
that my Cloud Function needs.
To do this, I'll head over to
the Secret Manager Console,
select my secret, expand the
Info panel, click Add Member,
and grant my Cloud Function
Service account permissions
to access the secret.
Here, I apply the IAM
policy at the secret level,
meaning my Cloud Function
won't have access
to the other secrets
in my project.
I could also grant this
permission using the gcloud
command line tool, or from the
API using any of the Secret
Manager SDKs for .NET, Go, Java,
Node, PHP, Python, and Ruby.
Google Secret Manager makes
it easy to adopt and practice
the principle of
least privilege.
That's all for this episode.
In the next episode, we'll
talk about audit logging
and forensics with
Secret Manager.
Be sure to like, subscribe,
and click the bell
to get notifications
about new episodes.
For even more tips and tricks
with Google Secret Manager,
click Subscribe to
Google Cloud Platform.
[MUSIC PLAYING]